At the age of 16 he had a master plan for becoming one of the best,
no generalists in all of Britain.
He's been in the midst of media scandals.
He's interviewed some of the most famous celebrities and most powerful
politicians in the world,
and he's judged the talents of hundreds of common folks.
Arrogance,
ambitious and shameless.
Well,
who is this media man?
of course it's none other than Piers Morgan.
Okay.
He is.
Morgan was born in Sussex.
That's in England in 1965 to an Irish dentist who unfortunately died when Morgan
was only two years old.
Morgan was named peers.
Stephan,
Oh Mira.
But Morgan's mother remarried after his father's death and Morgan,
he adopted the surname cute Morgan Morgan and his stepfather.
They were pretty close and Morgan having never really known as birth farmer
calls Him Dad,
his parents,
they weren't middle class English.
They ran a pub and they supported Maggie Thatcher.
When Morgan was 13 years old,
the family could no longer afford to send him to private school,
so he had to leave behind the classmates that he knew that his new school,
well,
he was picked on and in true schoolboy fashion,
the name Q,
well that was changed to puke.
They are hilarious,
aren't made Morgan,
as you probably know,
he dropped few from his name later on.
I believe that some have attributed to a desire to separate from his middle
class roots.
That's that Morgan himself just said was because p Morgan was too long for a
byline as a Charles Morgan.
He showed an early affinity for the media as early as age seven he would sit at
the table devouring the daily newspapers,
reading the headlines and discussing the day's events with his parents.
Now.
By the time he was a teenager,
he was already writing news articles,
even actually sold a piece to the mid Sussex Times and then do cricket magazine
at the age of 2014 he said,
if this,
it gave me the real taste of the excitement of a byline.
It's probably no surprise to youth and that a couple of years later when it was
time for a career to happen,
Morgan had set his mind on the fact that he would become the most famous media
personality in all of Britain.
He developed this master plan and ops is not to take an offer from Warrick
university to study history.
The reason for this was simply because this would have kept his master plan or a
hold for a few years while he completed his education.
So instead he went directly to Harlow college and don't have it into the formal
study of journalism as soon as he could.
Okay.
Wilkins first formal journalism Gig,
was it the south London News and then he joined the sun's right,
the gossip column,
which was entitled,
bizarre as The Guardian put it.
Morgan spent his years at the sun,
grinning in namely,
while posing next to a succession of personalities.
He was,
wasn't disagree with the Guardian's characterization.
It was an initial years in the media as he himself told the BBC,
he made a point of putting himself in the middle of stories,
posing for pictures with celebrities and generally his name has face out there
for all of Britain.
And to see while this tactic,
it totally works.
By 1994 at the age of only 20 million Morgan securities place in British media
history.
When Rupert Murdoch named him as editor of the news of the world's Piers Morgan,
he was the youngest editor ever of the news of the world.
And as the youngest editor of a paper in Britain in five decades,
the news of the world had the largest circulation of any paper in the country at
the time.
And the editor Shep gave Morgan a platform in which to put his hard charging,
oft controversial journalistic methods on display for a huge population of
readers even held reach,
the previously untouchable barricade of the royal family.
By the summer of 1994 Princess Diana and Prince Charles is marriage ed was on
its way to its official ends and Oregon and the news of the welds.
They weren't going to miss out on the opportunity to publish on potentially
juicy Ronald scandals.
Wolgan his court wins that James Hew as an officer in the British military
wanted to spill the beans about his affair with Princess Diana with no fear of
potential repercussion or for the long held level of dignity with which the
roles had been treated.
Morgan reached down to it and arranged to interview him for a story.
He and his associate,
they actually even bugs the room where they did the interview so they would have
absolute proof of everything that was set.
Then leads to that year in the fall,
a book about Prince Charles and his private life.
It was set to be published while the news of the worlds that they didn't have
any excerpts the Sunday Times.
Totally did Morgan well.
He wasn't ready to give a scoop to another paper and nausea willing to take no
as an answer when he was denied access to information from the Sunday Times.
Instead,
he directed Rebecca back of Seward,
helps him out on the hotel interview to disguise herself,
sneak into the Sunday Times officers,
grab a copy and get it back to the news of the world as quickly as possible.
Well,
this a little bit of espionage.
It totally worked.
And the news of the world,
they were able to publish the story about Diana and Charles all long before any
other paid the except for the Sunday Times.
So if Piers Morgan wanted to be a really famous journalists,
I mean why did he settle for running gossipy relationship stories?
Well,
the answer was because to him everything was news.
There is a type of snobbish pompous journalist who thinks that the only news
that has any validity is war,
famine,
pestilence or politics.
I don't come from that school,
this egalitarian attitude.
It's allowed Morgan too quickly prove as metal and his willingness to do
whatever it took to be successful in breaking stories that he only lasted at the
news of the world for a bit over a year.
Though Morgan said he left the publication of his own accord.
The timing of his exec coincide with the publication of a photo of Princess
Diana's sister in law leaving and addiction treatment clinic.
The publication of which even Rupert Murdoch said went too far now in 1995
shortly after this photo around Morgan,
he moved on to head up the mirror and other paper roads by Rupert Murdoch here
has tenure.
It lasted much longer than it did at the news of the world.
The number of controversial stories though it was much larger than man as a
result,
his profile but continued to rise even outside of Britain,
but it's true to form.
It only took a year before Morgan found himself in his first major controversy
at the mirror.
The day before England was set to play Germany and the euro 96 football
championships.
The Mirror ran a headline and the folks when it's front page that many did not
find very amusing above a doctored image of two players wearing world war two
helmets was the headliner act will not surrender for you.
Fritz Zero 96 championship is over next to it was a letter written by Morgan
himself in the style of Neville Chamberlain.
Reportedly Morgan also plans a publicity stunt than involved driving a tank to
the German embassy.
In the ensuing uproar about the headline,
well that lead to stunt,
it was subsequently canceled.
Suddenly though Morgan,
he found himself in this position that is hard charging personality.
It didn't seem suited for you.
Got to apologize.
There were fears,
the kind of attitude you promoted by the headlight made site acts of violence
during the games though Morgan,
he was apologizing.
He was still right where he wants it to be and of course that would be the
center of attention.
In 2000 though,
the attention turns from an editorial decision he had made to a more personal
financial scandal.
I can.
These in newspaper published the story alleging that Morgan had bought 20,000
pounds worth of stock in a computer company and that he had made the purchase
just before the mirror ran a piece naming the stock as a good buy and inquiry
began and it was just to hit the wall and Morgan had breached an ethical code of
conduct.
He could keep his job.
Other mirror employees,
well,
they weren't so lucky.
Economist,
so you wrote on stock vice,
they lost their jobs and it was another four years before Morgan was cleared of
any wrongdoing.
However,
it actually came out later that he'd bought additional stock under his wife's
name and another 70,000 pounds worth by the time that that later revelation came
about,
it was Morgan was already on the skids at the mirror.
I just said he had been leading the charge against the Iraq war in the British
press,
undoubtedly criticizing then Prime Minister Tony Blair for his support.
Supportive.
The ball among the story is published on the war and the Morgans leadership was
a piece that included a photo of British soldiers abusing Iraqi prisoners.
As recently as eight 2016 BBC Interview Oregon,
he defended the photos seeing if they were real and that the British government
had a vested interest in getting rid of me.
Their biggest thorn in the side about the war.
However,
the mirror,
it didn't defend them strongly in the wake of the allegations that they were
actually fake.
The British people.
Instead,
they actually got a paper with a large headline that that stage,
sorry,
we will host and then the man who had,
okay,
the publication of the photos,
well,
he was subsequently out of a job when Morgan's firing was announced to staff
members at the paper.
They were in tears after nearly a decade.
Piers Morgan's reign of the Daily Mirror.
It was over.
Yeah,
free to form though.
He absolutely did not slink away into the night.
Instead,
he became a regular feature on people's TV screens that we had already been
appearing on TV before leaving the newspaper business.
Morgan stepped up his involvement with broadcast media after it's firing.
One of the first offers Morgan received for a regular TV Gig was via a text
message from signing cow and then in 2000 and America welcomed Morgan into their
homes as he served as a judge on America's got talent.
You also judge Britain's,
got talent,
and even appeared on the Venn,
just a mogul.
Donald trumps reality show the celebrity apprentice Morgan actually won his
season of the celebrity apprentice and in the process became close friends with
now President Donald Trump.
Orkin said all along that he believed to Trump would be president and just being
outspoken about his dislike for the protests that erupted after Trump's
election.
Interestingly,
Morgan style trines on the subject of even that some celebrities do decline
interviews with him,
but Morgan,
he knew what opening his mouth could lead to.
He's no stranger to the INS and outs of the American political and media
institutions.
He served as the host of eight primetime show on CNN for several years after
all.
So when Larry King announced his retirement in 2010 Morgan was named as the
replacement for the long time.
My chronic American host,
the show,
it started strong with Morgan able to book some of the biggest names in media
and politics for interviews.
Oprah,
Rudy Gilani,
Ricky Gervais',
Condoleezza Rice,
and even two of the con ashy and sisters bands.
Well,
he made just as many headlines for the interviews he didn't do as well.
Madano was deemed too old to appear on his show and his bands from ever being a
guest,
but it's unfortunately for Morgan,
the initial hype,
it wore off quickly.
Morgan had a different style from king and he was a British person taking over
in American news and interview show.
Ultimately he lost it.
Be Three years in the host chair has poor ratings.
Student into failure is attributed to the you failure to a clash of cultures
citing such factors as his own outspoken opposition to guns as one such example
of cultural differences that just couldn't be bridged.
The CNN show though it wasn't Morgan's only projects during that time period.
It was also hosting life stories for like TV,
who subjects were as diverse as Sharon Osborne and the prime minister.
And now today he's the permanents cohost for good morning Britain where he keeps
himself in the spotlight,
mostly recently sparring with a gender fluid guest over the validity.
You have gender fluidity in this interview and it's pretty classic blunt style.
Morgan,
ask the 21 year old guest if you can identify as whoever the hell would you
like.
Come on.
You literally look at myself and say,
I'm an elephant today.
Yeah,
limits.
Does Reutens do television.
Stardom Morgan had to contend with accusations dating back to his newspaper days
80,005 the news of the world,
which remember Morgan headed up for a year,
published a story about Prince Harry injuring himself.
The only way that they could have gotten the details for that story you've
claimed royal officials was if they had hacked personal voicemails.
This set of a series of event,
the rocks of the British media,
political and celebrity world arrested swim eight investigations were done.
Law seats were files and it took six years before some actual action was taken
to address the phone hacking scandal,
river archaea.
She'd apologies for the phone hacking and prince in the form of a full page ads.
In the last issue of the news of the world,
Rebecca Brooks,
the same Rebecca who Morgan it used to break into the Sunday Times office
resigned as CEO of news international alter their resignation.
They more bad news is headed because she was arrested,
but then she was released on bail.
The FBI then opens their own investigation into the news of the world and the
allegations that they were hacking the phones of nine 11 victims.
Indeed,
this scandal was so wide ranging that even London's police department was
investigated for corruption.
Needless to say,
well,
the scandal,
it's totally envelop to England.
The wells,
it was paying attention though Morgan had been out of the newspaper world for
some time.
He was not immune to being questioned about the scandal.
In fact,
he had to answer questions regarding to the voicemails.
If one of England's most famous personas,
so Paul Mccartney,
Mccartney,
his ex wife,
Heather Mills,
had alleged that her voicemails have been listened to after she and Mccartney
had had a fight in 2001 a reporter who called her just seem to know too much and
Mel's maintain that she hadn't shared the voicemails with anyone else and that
she had actually deleted them all.
The only way the reporter could have known so much was if he had hacked or
listen to the voicemails or talk to someone who hat Morgan and it that he had
heard a message from Mccartney to mills and as a result he was called to testify
and the 2011 inquiry into phone hacking,
Morgan wouldn't reveal how it come to hear the message and he also maintains
that he never authorized the hacking of voicemails or the news of the welds or
the Daily Mirror,
the head of the phone hacking inquiry,
Lord Levison Goldberg and his testimony that he didn't know about the phone
hacking to be utterly unpersuasive as well.
Despite his denials of direct involvement in the hacking Morgan.
He was interviewed by the police about the hacking in both 2013 and 2015
okay.
Phone hacking,
incendiary headlines,
taping interviews about the royals,
your might thing that would be enough for any one person to face in the course
of a media career.
But Piers Morgan,
he has been embroiled in personal controversy with other celebrities as well.
One much publicized dramas,
diameter and action Morgan took is the editor of the Daily Mirror.
He published photos of top gear host Jeremy Clarkson with a woman who was not
his wife,
Clarkson and understandably was perturbed by these photos being put out there
for all of the world to see.
So what did parks and do well and he decided to her glass of water in Morgan's
face that's might not seem out of place in your average bar.
That on board,
the last flight of the Conchords,
the alteration,
well,
it stood out and the fact that it was between two,
you are highly visible members of the British media.
We're all even better a fuse between these two men.
Well,
it's officially started and this feud,
it wasn't minor thing.
It literally came to blows in 2004 when Clarkson punched Morgan in the head at
the national press awards.
Parkson broke a finger.
Morgan gained discard ans these celebrity gossip writers.
Well,
they gained a new story though the views linger for a few years.
The two men were able to bond over drinks in 2015 and while the feud end it at
the time,
Clarkson was going through a divorce and confided about his travels to Morgan
who was able to empathize.
I sensed that Jeremy's just pretty much like every other 50 something in life.
Angst-Ridden from damage,
relationships,
grieving,
loved ones,
irritated by work issues and battling in a demons.
Okay,
well at the time he entered his fifties Morgan was acquainted with many of the
same trials and tribulations that Clarkson had dealt with.
His own marriage fell apart by the mid two thousands when he had his first wife
and married and shallow officially divorced in 2008 after 27 years of marriage,
the marriage,
it produced three sons and Morgan makes a point of staying in close contact with
his children.
In fact,
amidst all of the demands on his time,
Oregon has made a point of speaking to his children every single day.
Often is divorce Morgan.
He began dating Celia walls in a fellow journalist,
the couple the married in 2010 and years later they had a daughter.
They both are British.
They now primarily reside in New York.
Walden often shares details of their married life in her columns and Morgan even
joins in some of the time the team even teams up to write a column about a trip
to Paris in which Morgan steps back from his desire to be known by everyone.
Ferris has always been one of my favorite cities because the French neither knew
who I am nor camp.
This means I can behave in a wildly reckless manner and to maintain a reasonable
confidence that the shameful images will never appear on the cover of the
national enquirer.
Though he claims he doesn't want his own personal shame.
Shout in the national enquirer,
Morgan has made a career out of sharing the intimate details of other people's
lives.
He's never been shy about sharing his political opinions or any opinions.
He's made a name for himself.
He's made a few enemies along the way and shows absolutely no sign of stepping
out of the spotlight anytime soon.
From Middleclass Sussex.
Do you have a TV sets of people around the wells?
Here's Morgan has lived out the plan.
He wrote it at the age of 17 and he's still got plenty of Korea and left to go.
What will the world see next from Piers Morgan?
Well,
whatever it is,
when it happens,
well,
we'll surely see it in the news.
So that was piers Morgan his life.
Well so far.
If you didn't like this video,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Do not forget to subscribe for brand new videos every Monday and Thursday.
Check out some of our other videos for all the past over there on the rise and
as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.